Malaysia's former Prime Minister Najib
Razak is expected to face five trials
this one could be the most significant
it involves more than half a billion
dollars linked to a one MBD state fund
but allegedly ended up in his bank
account in this case he faces 25 counts
of money laundering and abuse of power
none of the people who were charged with
corruption of the old regime now that
they had been put in jail and people are
waiting to see whether this government
can deliver the promises that made in
the last election which is to mention
that Najib and people are wrong and will
go to jail over this massive corruption
corruption allegations have been
weighing on a jeep and his inner circle
for years as Prime Minister he set up
the state investment fund in 2009 to
stimulate Malaysia's economy but
eventually it amassed billions in debt
and now the United States and other
countries are looking into alleged
cross-border
embezzlement in 2016 Najib was cleared
of criminal activity after 10 million
dollars were reportedly funneled to his
personal account he denied any
wrongdoing saying the funds were a
donation from the Saudi royal family but
other charges followed the trials are
largely seen as a test on the country's
political transparency
Malaysia's current prime minister
mahathir mohamad has promised a
crackdown on corruption and to pursue
all charges against the former leader
Najib's legal team insists the
accusations are politically motivated
and baseless while the political career
of the former prime minister is over the
focus now shifts to his fate in court
Katya Lewis of the Y on al-jazeera